a young adult presents to the office
with body aches fatigue and joint pain
what happened next may surprise you
let's get started
before i walk in to see the patient i
actually do a chart review to see if the
patient has been seen before what the
vitals are what information has been
shared with my medical assistant and i
find out that the patient has actually
seen several other doctors over the last
few weeks for the same issue and hasn't
gotten a satisfactory answer meaning a
diagnosis or treatment to solve the
issue in looking through the notes i saw
that the patient was initially diagnosed
with arthritis that they attributed to
the patient being overweight his bmi i
think put him into the category of
morbid obesity while that can cause
osteoarthritis
he seemed to be a little bit too young
for that to start happening i walk in to
see the patient i introduce myself one
of the first questions is what has been
the diagnosis thus far what have other
doctors told you you went to see a
doctor first who diagnosed a patient
with arthritis related to his weight the
treatment for that was some
over-the-counter medications which i
thought was a rather incomplete
treatment even if that was the correct
diagnosis then the patient said when
they went home and tried the
over-the-counter options the pain did
not get better at all in fact it got
worse and then a rash appeared so the
patient over the weekend went to an
urgent care facility where they gave the
patient a cream when i investigated what
the cream was it happened to be a
topical steroid and the rashes did go
away with the cream however
over the period of about 10 days the
pain
in the joints in the muscles
specifically the knees the elbows
started to return for the patient so he
came back to that same doctor and said
hey why am i not getting better with the
treatment what's going on and the doctor
made some other evaluations and ended up
sending the patient for x-rays to see if
there was anything going on uh from the
imaging side of things and again
reiterated to the patient that the
suspicion was all the symptoms were
coming from the fact that the patient
was overweight clearly that wasn't the
issue if you look at the course of
illness for this patient the fact that
it was getting worse there's not only
joint pain but there's also body aches
there's also fatigue setting in rash is
starting to happen these are multiple
systems being involved and that tells me
something systemic is going on i decided
to ask the patient if he sent a message
to any of his friends of the rashes
typically we do that right we're like oh
my god what is this and we take a
picture with our iphones and to my luck
he did he took a picture of the rash
early on when it started and it looked
like an erythematous meaning very red
rash of the skin he only had a picture
of one of them but he said all of them
looked quite similar now this is unique
because
the fact that it's not happening again
in one area tells me that it's not an
isolated or localized reaction to
something if i have a reaction right
where my watch is that tells me
something is going on in this area
either there's a contact dermatitis
where i'm allergic to one of the
components of the watch maybe a fungal
infection from trapping of the moisture
so the the localized nature of the rash
would tell me something but when we have
a rash that's happening all across the
body that means something's happening
internally whether it's in the blood in
the lymphatic system i need to think
further so i started putting pieces
together and i said wait you have
fatigue
joint pain body aches a rash does this
patient have lyme disease so i asked the
patient uh does he spend a lot of times
outdoors hiking gardening and he said no
absolutely not i'm kind of a homebody i
like to stay home i don't really go
outside much and i'm like do you have a
dog and he's like yeah i love my dog i
sleep with my dog i'm like has your dog
ever had a tick i see his eyes open wide
and he says yes my dog i actually pulled
a tick off of him not that long ago the
way that we get exposed to ticks is not
only through being outdoors and in tall
grass but through carriers or vectors
like bear can literally
run into a big forested area get a bunch
of ticks on his fur and him being brown
me not see it climbs into my bed leaves
one of the ticks next to me and they
could easily start feeding and cause an
infection every other provider he's seen
this far wrote him off as just an
allergy needing some medications it's
all due to his weight weight is a
problem for a lot of my patients a lot
of my patients do suffer with their
quality of life because they fall into
the category of morbid obesity but it's
also not right to blame everything
that's going on
without doing a proper history and
physical like that gets lost right then
and there so at this point we make a
decision that i think what's going on is
that the patient had an erythema
migraines rash but what's unique is
erythema migraines sometimes appears
with multiple lesions throughout the
body and sometimes they're all
completely red and they don't all look
like the prototypical bullseye rash that
we study in our textbooks but then i
started having to think the patient
actually has early disseminated lyme
disease why because he's starting to
have joint pain migratory arthritis body
aches which is myalgia is basically pain
in the muscles that means the
inflammation is spreading and unless we
catch these and act appropriately it
could lead to further lyme late lime
which is very problematic because then
it could spread to your heart causing
things like arrhythmias av blocks
neurologic complications we had to act
quickly we drew blood then and there to
do two tests one the elisa test to make
the initial diagnosis of lyme disease
and then a western blot to do the
confirmation test for it and then right
away prescribe the course of doxycycline
which is an antibiotic that we like to
use for the treatment of life patient
follows up two weeks later what do we
find out a his lyme test both positive b
he feels a hundred times better zero
fatigue zero joint pain zero muscle
aches he's completely cured had he
progressed to late-stage lyme disease
and had neurologic or cardiac
complications he may have needed a
hospital stay for iv antibiotics he
could have lost his life as a result of
a cardiac arrhythmia if you happen to be
a patient and you feel your provider is
overly focused on your weight and you
feel like you're not getting good care
because of that you have two options
option one be direct point out to your
provider that you feel like there's an
over emphasis on your weight and while
you know it is an important factor in
your health it's not the sole
determinant of your health and you'd
like to have a further discussion on
that if they're not receptive move to
option two or if you don't even wanna
have that conversation that's your
choice to move to option two which is
seek a second opinion that is your right
as a patient and insurance cannot deny
you for seeking a second opinion because
medicine is as much art as it is a
science the relationship between a
provider and a patient has to be strong
in order for uh proper health outcomes
to occur
i want to stress this
super strongly be careful with certain
health providers who make the diagnosis
of a condition which is not really a
correct condition of chronic lyme
disease they say that you need to do all
sorts of treatments like chelation
therapies extremely long courses of
antibiotics that have no real evidence
for them and they blame a lot of my
patients symptoms on this chronic lyme
disease when in reality that's not
what's going on if someone's pushing on
you expensive lengthy complex treatments
seek a second opinion either with
another primary care doctor or even an
infectious disease specialist because
there's a lot a lot of fraud and
malpractice that happens in this area
and i've seen my patients truly suffer
that's just one of my patient stories
but click here to check out my bizarre
life as an attending doctor as always
stay happy and healthy click here to
check that out
[Music]